today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block pizza 18:11
Pico Boulevard on the way to the beach
and Los Angeles gray block get that hit
or baby oh man
you know I was a I was a unreasonable
child if you'd have seen me when I was a
child I was I was unreasonable
you know I'd wear a tank top sometimes
in the winter and then I just just just
yell at people about how cold I was I'm
cold and people were like we you got a
tank top on and I'd be like eat my ass
buddy so I was that kind of kid you know
the kind of kid that you know I'd wear
like a little rain jacket or something
in new uh in the reek air whatever it
was
pre-k a recap I was in all the case I
was a I was in pre-k K reek a 3k I was
in 3 that was the I think at one point I
thought it was Klu Klux Klan but uh but
it was just continual continual
kindergarten and they spelled continual
with a K but I was in there man and I'd
wear you know sometime a slicker like a
rain slicker you know like that really
what really should be called the the
11th wonder of the world and that rain
slicker because how the it's amazing how
the whole force of nature rain can be
stopped by just one layer of slicker
plastic but I would wear that bastard
broad wear that bright yellow bastard
right now in the dead of summer in at
school and I'd be complaining in the
class but it's hot it's hot as hell in
there
miss Louis and they'd be like you you
got a slicker on boy
you got a you better get that it ain't
even raining you got a slicker on I mean
like eat my ass guys um you know I'm
doing my best so I think I was just
probably does an unreasonable child
[Music]
[Music]
that would almost show
[Music]
that is um every night by Jamison flood
it's a music man and he sent that in a
long time ago whenever this saw when the
pod first kicked out when this pod first
just just was that first just you know
just kind of flowed into the verse bruh
into that uni I want to tell you got
some new tour dates back onto the books
10 for October 4th and Bethlem PA at the
wind Creek event center that is back on
10-5 now that's a Saturday I will be in
Pittsburgh at a theater there I don't
have the name but the the tickets are
all on the website theof on comm / tour
Cleveland is back on that's October 8th
the ninth is Indianapolis the 10th is
Grand Rapids the 11th is Detroit
Michigan the 12th is Milwaukee Wisconsin
and the 13th is Madison Wisconsin and
those are just one show a night so
making some adjustments to get that get
a little more calm to get a little a
little bit more calm in my water you
know some of the water inside of me some
mom has just been ended been damn
drastic like these hurricanes coming in
they have a new hurricane I think yo-yo
breath or something this thing who knows
I don't know I will say this if they're
gonna build a wall let's build it over
there on Florida and stop these because
some of these canes are coming in
illegally I will say that a lot of canes
rolling into this bastard on the IL brah
and the short fair legal I got
information here two men I'm not going
to do the film
in Atlanta so it uh I got there did the
training everything was cool
and the part was just for the amount of
time commitment and for the sacrifice of
shows and of other stuff I have going on
here once I saw the part it just wasn't
for me it wasn't it was too much on the
scale of all you can't you can't be
there for eight to ten weeks for this
role so the role just didn't fit you
know I thought about it and talked with
you know people I trust and friends and
people who were have more experience
than I do for a few days and got that
you know communication I got straight
communication with others and and that
was that and then I just made that
choice I'd talked to the director talked
to Chris Pratt about it and that was
that and that was my decision
there was no ill will there was no bad
vibes you know it was just at some point
I just had to trust my instincts it was
just like all for me right now this role
you know and I didn't I didn't get to
see the script before I went so there
wasn't the opportunity for me to see
what my part was going to be and I think
there was a little bit of
miscommunication but I don't think it
was anybody's fault and and that was
that I'm thankful that I was able to
decommitted
causing any problems and I'm grateful
that I even you know was considered and
that I even had the opportunity to do it
you know I think there's some parts
about it that I'll miss out on doing you
know but it was just
time commitment for the stuff for this
for the role for what the role ended up
being for me wasn't it just didn't work
for me it didn't work for me and some
people will be like well you know you I
mean you got to take it it's a movie but
you know I have a lot I mean I have you
know I already have enough kind of
responsibilities going on and and that
was it that was just a choice I had to
trust my instincts you know I had to
trust my instincts and that was and that
was it
so I'm bummed man I had you know I had
visions in my head of eating hot dogs
and stuff with uh with Christopher
Pratt's and doing you know maybe you
know having a second hot dog or sitting
in chat and you know conversations going
well we're talking about baseball or
something or having a couple peanuts or
something and I had you know visions
like that in my head you know us doing
something maybe going to uh I don't know
doing you know throwing coins and a
wishing well or something and just
hoping for the best or you know maybe
you know maybe I had visions of us maybe
uh you know driving in like a jeep or
something but nothing wild or anything
nothing sexual or anything like that I
just had you know fun ideas in my head
you know or maybe us you know doing you
know nothing crazy but just looking for
you know maybe looking at art or
something you know somewhere or um you
know or maybe throwing those circus
peanuts those beautiful little you know
orange [ __ ] you know soft hard hitters
throwing those into each other's mouths
and stuff from kind of close range but
then getting further and further apart
you know you know until it got too dark
out to see them and throw them back and
forth and catch them in your mouth but
ah but but you know that's that and and
you know I yeah I know that like if I
get to be in a film or something it's
not going to be
you know it isn't in my movie you know
but I do want to be able to be in a role
where I feel like I can at least do some
stuff that you get that my personality
maybe works well in and yeah and this
wasn't anybody's fault it was just sort
of just kind of you know I just had to
trust my instincts and stuff once I once
I was able to you know read the part and
look at it and I still think Christopher
Pratt's probably one of the top you know
15 or maybe I don't know you know 18 or
even probably I don't know I bet he'd be
on gods fantasy team though and so you
know that's all good and communication
was there was a up front communication
and and yeah hopefully maybe be some
other opportunities we'll see you know
but that you know I just had to kind of
trust my instincts I'm we and and and if
I sound down right now well it's because
Drew Brees got hurt man he got hurt and
you know you could just and it's so
funny I was watching the game and the
Saint this New Orleans Saints and the
Los Angeles Rams who most people even
have not even heard of that team but
they were going at it and it was
exciting right in the beginning and and
then drew Brees got hurt and it was so
funny I would have rather dois ch when
the camera would cut to him
you got to see somebody you know here he
has he's 40 years old and and the injury
looks kind of like it could be bad you
know he couldn't even pick up a football
and it just
he couldn't even grip that freaking pig
that little that little you know
deceased brown pig getting it crazy that
a football is a pig that he used to be a
pig and now it's just you know they cut
off the head and tied off the ends of it
and
those white you know try to kind of give
it some white stitches or something by
the liver and now they're throwing it
around man
I mean this you know we think we're so
far removed from what is it called uh
not the Ice Age or something but um
bestiality no you know we think we're so
far removed from I don't know what it's
called Neolithic the Neo pale old days
the old days let's agree with that we
think we're so far removed from the old
days but then here you see you know
bunch of guys throwing around that uh
just throwing around that that little
ripped up swine chunk and you're like
damn we are we are still we are a little
bit stuck in the past you know but uh
was I talking about but yeah but drew
brees got hurt in and at some point I
was enjoying not enjoying that I was
there was more every time the camera cut
to him and it was just so much it was
more entertaining than the game because
I was watching this man who had you know
this was a man who had the world on his
back and who you could tell how just how
determined he was and how focused he was
in every game you can tell it like he's
playing the game but he's also playing
this bigger game like what he's doing
right now always seems like just a move
in a grander scheme of his life like and
he's able to do both at the same time it
always seems like and you were just
seeing him just how limited he was by
the circuit by the by the moment you
know you could see him and he couldn't
and how limited he was by his vessel by
his own body he couldn't grip that hand
he couldn't close that hand up and he
couldn't grip a football and he couldn't
express himself you know when you
started to just see a man that was
limited by you know it's like even
whatever that desire
fire inside of us that that want you
know where it's all limited a little bit
by the revered the reality by the
actuality of what's going on by
circumstance and and man that was a much
greater game to me was just seeing the
look in his eyes the mental game that it
was going on inside of him trying to
hold his composure and trying to trying
to almost in the moment find out who he
was when suddenly he was you is when
suddenly the the path he had been on
came to an abrupt like there weren't any
more there was no more paths for it just
came to it like a cul-de-sac and you
were trying he had just so much energy
so many people behind him soon I mean so
many Saints fans you saw him winning a
championship again you saw him you know
you already had these visions of him
like hugging his kids again under the
whatever that is um
paper the paper the little paper rain
[ __ ] man my brain is a stalled out dude
what is my brain a Datsun the [ __ ] is
sitting needs oil but you saw him
stalled out the confetti you saw you
know and you just saw and suddenly
everything stopped man all of it it just
and you saw him trying to find out from
or that's what I saw I saw man
struggling to know who he was at this
moment when the world had taken you know
a different a different turn you know
when when the reality that whatever we
want always isn't what's going to happen
or that things aren't gonna work out
perfectly or that when reality strikes
you know and man and it broke your heart
as a fan it broke your heart as a human
I feel like to see someone with so much
capability and so many people who look
up to him or look at him as a figure of
direction an example and suddenly he you
see him come almost even though he
didn't put himself into the atmosphere
you see him and and and I did I put him
up in the atmosphere I put him up you
see him come back down to earth and it's
uh I don't know it was man it was it was
hectic man that was a hectic moment um
we got some we got we got look today you
know I know that we've been you know
we've had a couple of guys recently that
have called in the young fellow who had
the surprise baby to that's God I mean
well we're gonna check in with those
people you know we're gonna give him
that ring-a-ling and see what's cracking
over there in their hood especially that
surprise baby boy like that's what I'm
saying who is it what's going on here
knock knock who's there and then tada
you know gestation they got that baby
that hit or that zygote that's got to be
crazy if you think you know you just you
oh yeah
so we're gonna find out how that all
went down because that fella just didn't
know they were having a baby and and we
will get into we're getting to a call
also i'ma give a call over to the Big
Dawg himself mr. drippy mitts you know
and that boy had that water hanging and
he had that unique water hand and so
we're gonna get into some of that and uh
and just see what's going on we had a
call that came in and I'll get to that
in just a second I want to let you I
wanna I just want to let you know we got
to pay the bill you know it the hiring
process can be slow and you know that if
you're trying to hire somebody and they
come by the house and they you know they
I remember some time they park in your
yard you're not getting a job if you
parked on my [ __ ] azalea's brah you
out you know I remember one time my mom
was hiring somebody to do something in
the house fixed the all the cabinet had
fallen down because my brother and I put
a little bit of fire in it actually
and uh and this and this fella [ __ ]
him and his buddy camped out in our yard
for like a week and a half and never did
the work either so pieces of [ __ ] but
anyway hiring can be a slow process
well cafe alturas co Odilon mich o wits
needed to hire a director of coffee for
his organic coffee company but he was
having trouble finding qualified
applicants so he switched to zip
recruiter zip recruiter it doesn't
depend on candidates finding you it
finds them for you what are you looking
for your ear ear pods nope a candidate
it's technology identifies people with
the right experience and invites them to
apply to your job so you get qualified
candidates fast dylan posted his job on
zip recruiter and said he was impressed
by how quickly he had great candidates
apply and that's how ill and found his
new director of coffee in just a few
days with results like that it's no
wonder four out of five employers who
post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day see why
zip recruiters effective for businesses
of all sizes try zip recruiter for free
at our web address zip recruiter dot-com
slash tpw that's zip recruiter dot-com
slash tpw zip recruiter comm slash t pw
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire
we got some great calls that came in and
uh let's do it this is the last ad and
we're gonna get it through this this
episode also look if you if you need to
find somebody to work for you
you guys zip recruiter okay if you need
a skill to take to an employer you got
skills share skills share boy think
about something you could do learn how
to make a nice mole a you know or mole
or whatever you know what i'm talking
about the sauce you never order at the
mexican place because you don't know how
to say and some people risk thinking
it's actual mole people like damn I'm
not eating mole you know I have a little
cut a vowel but I ain't having any mole
boy you know no mole for me Skillshare
is an on
learning community for create tours with
more than 25,000 classes and design
business and more you'll discover so
many ways to fuel your curiosity and
your creativity and if you want to give
yourself a new career
you could have classes they have all
type of learning classes in social media
mobile mobile photography creative
writing even illustration all the things
you wanted to do you could do it now
first you need the skill hey what's up
when you got the skill note well you can
graphic design try graphic design basics
core principles for visual design one of
the popular courses join the millions of
students already learning on Skillshare
today and support the podcast get two
months of Skillshare for free that's
right skills share is offering this past
weekend listeners two months of
unlimited access to over 25,000 classes
for free to sign up go to Skillshare
comm slash Theo von
again go to Skillshare comm slash Theo
von to start your two months now that
skill shared comm slash Theo von yeah we
have some calls that have come in we got
a lot you know and I listen to all of
them this weekend and and thank you a
lot of them some zeal dirty one guy
doing just doing gas doing body gas into
the you know receiver one guy tickling
somebody in his truck dude you know I
act and actually you know what thank you
for that one that was actually probably
one of the better ones but a lot of
great calls that came in and so we will
and let's get into a couple of those
right now as always the hotline is nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three and then I'm going to make a few
calls on my own to some of some of the
recent calls that have come in and get
some follow-up let's get into this one
gang Zachary Quinto called it from
Cincinnati was of Zachary and a friend
of mine actually over there in
Cincinnati he would had a couple
milkshakes one time and this was late at
night and they had two sisters out
there is one lady this herb enough you
know this beautiful urban lady named I
think vasectomy I think was her name
actually a exotic dancer
vasectomy Harper and anyway she and this
other lady were fist fighting one night
in Cincinnati and he went over there to
make a video of him and his pants fell
down because he was kind of chubby and
you know and I guess that doesn't matter
that he was chubby his pants didn't his
pants first of all they were shorts so
they weren't pants and they just he just
dressed like [ __ ] this man Gary was his
name and so anyway his pants hit the
floor and and he was video recording the
ladies and vasectomy and this other lady
really came over and beat his ass and he
tried to keep the milkshakes without
spilling them the whole time while he
was getting beaten and uh
and that should be a damn Olympic sport
you know just just you know just riding
leche if you got to you know handfuls uh
you know the beautiful little sweet
let's say liquids and you got a couple
of sisters a couple of you know a couple
of wild ladies beating that ass and you
got a seat you know try and keep as much
a shake as you can in the cup and maybe
it could be called a cup that shake and
you got to keep as much as you can and
they can only beat you for like a
certain amount of time but anyway thank
you for calling homeward and I was just
trying to see if you had any advice on
getting of your first love honestly I
was 18 when I first met this girl and
now I'm 20 and she was my first
everything first girlfriends first love
we had gotten a doll together and
everything I thought we were in it for
the long run you know and she finally
broke up with me and oh you got that dog
together this is something that's going
on these days um this is something that
is going on a relationship animal and
you got to shut it down if it's a real
type of animal if it's a fish dude or
you and your girl you know y'all split a
cricket or something you know where
y'all go half seas on a little oyster
you know we're a Lazare
brother that's fine but once you go and
get a puppy or something that can really
look at you and maybe remember a little
bit of [ __ ] you know a strong mouse or
whatever you're creating havoc within
the NK brother the nature kingdom
because you because you got a joint
animal now you got the animals she's got
the animal y'all split up what is that
now he's doing what now he's all scared
he starts wetting the bed at night you
know he hears y'all arguing in the
kitchen and [ __ ] you know he starts
eating alone at school you know he
starts going home with other animals
that he's not even really interested in
you know he starts hiding under the bed
he starts you know he sees y'all going
y'all separate ways you know it's just
if you get a relationship animal that's
dangerous you know you know you know you
got an American Water Spaniel or
whatever he thinks it's his fault you
know he doesn't you know he quits aw you
know he's staying up late at night and
reading you know reading scary novels
you know you if you a relationship
animal it's just it's not that you can't
put that kind of pressure on an animal
if you gonna know you're married to the
person or whatever bring your own
animals into a relationship you don't
get an animal once you're together now
all that it just it's too much on that
animals back you know now you got you
know next thing you know you got a
raccoon out there he's vaping about a
recycling bin because he can't handle
his emotions because he doesn't know you
know who still cares about him you know
sure your little parakeets getting two
Christmases now but it just I think the
the risks of of it outweigh the reward
yeah and these relationship animals they
the two owners they start fighting and
they start giving both of them are given
the animal a treat oh here I got a treat
for you you love me you love Danny don't
you and you know I got a treat for you
you love Sandra and then the animal
doesn't know what to do is just treat it
out now it's all hopped up on treats
it's gained 3040 pounds
and next thing you know it's down there
at the damn methadone clinic so it's
just you can't don't get a relationship
animal
that's really all all that place is
going to be is just a cul-de-sac where
you get where you and your partner just
drive by and just throw y'all's [ __ ]
problems out into the street that's all
that relationship animal is so if you're
gonna get an animal get an animal for
yourself don't get this little halfway
house you know living creature that both
you guys are just using passively
aggressively towards one another don't
get because all you're really getting is
just a little passive-aggressive pet
where you guys are descending it this
way and sending it that way you notice a
little Paul Revere or whatever
yeah next and next thing you know it's
lashing out you know it's at the
parakeet park or whatever at a dog park
you know it's biting other things it's
[ __ ] stealing fruit or something over
about um
Vons or about um you know it's stealing
fruit over there about a winn-dixie it's
just you don't do it you know it's just
you're better than that you are better
than that and this animal deserves
better and it'll start thinking if it's
if it's his fault you know you'll see
sometimes somebody's a pet you know
these animals these relationship animals
and they're out there you'll see them
over there I see them off at a 101 at
night sometimes you know kicking a can
down the side of the interstate you know
just just I don't know I think is just
better ways to go about it that's what I
would say but anyway I'm really rambling
on word she's going back and sleeping
with her ex from hitting the fate of
another girl well now you you couldn't
do this do it if she's sleeping with her
ex you could put a little listening
device a little LD on that uh on that
animal so suddenly that little bastard
has a you know a purpose in the world
again because he's probably feeling like
nobody cares about him right now
but anyway man let me quit thinking
about that aspect of this and try and uh
listen to more what's going on with you
brother homework and I just don't know
what to do man it's just hard to go was
telling when they're your first you know
just really confused on what to do so if
you had any advice for diesel
really very appreciated yeah thanks for
the coal man that suggests you know I
was talking about this last week a
little law that that first love that's
that first that's that hot hose hit you
know it's like drinking off that hose in
the summer you know that house holds
that outdoor water spout and it hurts
man because that's the crazy thing about
a heart a heart really it's like a hand
brush it feels you know and your heart
just gets so used to just feeling
somebody it's almost like they're in
there and then when they're gone it's
like man there's just piece of your
heart that you you you just it's not
it's not you can't feel them in there
anymore and that hurts the saddest thing
is time a lot of is just going to be
time and one joy in it or and one thing
that's positive is that at least you
have that at least you care at least you
know that you can care about others you
can love others you've got that ability
to you got those uh what does it call
those pulmonary capabilities because if
you if you're the person who your
girlfriend leaves you don't give a damn
you just start doing construction or
whatever and you know people start going
missing in your town then that's
different then you are you're violent
you're a dark dark angel but that's not
you man
you know you're somebody that has some
feelings and uh and I'm sorry man I'm
sorry going through that because yeah it
sucks you know my first girlfriend I put
I put these motherly qualities on her
and so when she left me or when she when
she left me [ __ ] we were children did I
mean Jesus Christ it's not like I mean
both of us said who actually wanted to
leave somewhere we had to have our
parents pick us up but when uh when we
when we went our separate ways you know
I felt I remember I even remember I
remember saying I remember you I was
saying you can't leave me you know you
are my mom that's what I remember
telling her that's crazy that's how bent
I was emotionally you know because I
just attached all these feelings that
I'd never had a place to really attach
them that much
I had attached them to this girl and uh
and time helps man and don't do anything
drastic don't do anything crazy a little
hot on her porch or anything like that
and don't be out there you know by the
garbage and looking for [ __ ] or you know
just bypass all of that you know
sometimes dude sometimes you got to
stand on the sidelines and still look
like you like a man even though you know
things have changed you know the you
know just like Drew Brees man the day
that the Drew's ik the Drew's ik died
that's that's an old song nobody even
knew this [ __ ] whatever dude
but I'm sorry bro tighten up dude jeah
don't start masturbating and doing all
that don't look to pornography
hold the line you can do it go get a
Drew Brees Jersey and get back out there
bucko because I think you got this but
don't put all this pressure on that
animal you know don't be over there you
know trying to ask the animal you know
beating on the aquarium asking what it
heard you know was she having guys over
in the animal you know he's just like so
just don't whatever kind of animal y'all
got a snake or something don't [ __ ]
write dirty messages on the side of the
snake and let it loose on her side of
the apartment or whatever you know you
know the the world ends tonight and she
sees that you know if seashells pet run
by or something with a little sign on
its back if you got a little law you
know Australian Shepherd or whatever
just be a man there's a way to be a man
and go through this man a write a
country song listen a country dog get
some plug tobacco and drive out into the
distance and [ __ ] cry into a
stranger's ditch but if you want to know
what I really did and that's what I did
man
dude I used to [ __ ] I remember I
would be out there I was working on a
armed over their net outside of Natchez
Mississippi and I would dude I'll get a
big plug of tobacco until my whole face
burned and I had an AB natural reaction
so my face would turn real red when I
would do plug tobacco and goddamn I
looked like a I mean my [ __ ] was so
[ __ ] red I looked like a newborn I
look like a damn tall newborn with some
overalls on and uh and yeah I would just
do so much [ __ ] tobacco and sometimes
I would swallow it I was so angry that
me and this girl had broken up
I would swallow a big chunk of it and
just vomit off the back of that tractor
so but you can do it man you keep your
head up bruh I promise you man
you're gonna have you know there's gonna
be other opportunities for other love
around the corner men and different
types of love you're gonna love other
people differently but that that first
suck off that nectarine bro that first
you know got dang boy especially if
you're young brah you know when you can
be sober and have sex too when you're
young bro sober sex is for children and
I've always said that did if you see
some Stu sober adults [ __ ] brothers
[ __ ] is mmm mmm mmm mmm
I'm gonna throw up three or four dollars
in a church basket after that because
something it's just something it's it's
an awkward that's a tough deal that's a
par 30 right there brother all right
what do we got here actually this call
came in man let me throw this in your
ear right here here we go
hey what up Theo's is Brett from
California I'm just calling in because
I'm highest man I just went out on a
date I guess you could say with a girl
that I went to high school with you know
I'm like 26 now so things are a bit
different but man this is one of those
girls
we looked at you know saw pictures on
the internet or whatever woman just be
like wait out of my league
yeah oh man I remember one time there
was this girl Nicole was her name and uh
dude she liked me one time I found out
and I got high and I eat some mushrooms
and actually jumped over a fence at a
party right when she gave me her number
and ripped my hand open ripped and had
to go to the emergency room but um but
after that I kind of settled down and I
asked her on it to a dance and she went
with me and afterward bruh we're at my
buddy's apartment or his house his
parents house and he lived down in a
lower portion of their house they had a
lower portion and he lived there and I
was down there with her and she left me
you know and she had on a skirt dude and
I got it right up it kind of she was
sitting on a pool table and that's not
like a water table it's not like a I
don't people it's like a pool table you
know for the game pool with the stick
and the balls I'm not thinking of the
game of uh it's not like a pool like a
swimming pool yeah it sounds like that
it's not like a small pool you could eat
off of it's like a game and they had it
indoors and she's sitting on there dude
and she had on these uh well she had on
panties bra under you know and dude and
when you're young bro you get your hands
up near a girl's leg for everything my
neck was turning in circles bra my
tongue kept just flipped flip-flopping
back and forth over in my mouth like a
fish on the dock because I was just so
nervous dude and I got too nervous to
make the move on and I always regretted
that because I've you know I've hooked
up with some real you know some I've
hooked up with some some decent looking
ladies and some real you know kind of
chicks you might mean oh by the
interstate and uh but then I'll never
ever I've never I always regretted that
my god and she had these hips boy like
these kind of brown kind of like Bay
each kind of look like somebody just
kind of cooked her legs and butter a
little bit just beautiful skin tone
god damn she had those buttery just
[ __ ] hitters boy and I still think
about her sometimes man I still
sometimes closed my eyes and just want
to just bite the ass cheeks off that
little beautiful Falcon bra onward she's
way too out of my league but I I don't
know man I just shot my shot and took
her out today and the best time ever
dang I know I'm feeling like I should go
for it again but at the same time the
pensive because I'm intimidated I guess
by her attractiveness and at the same
time I don't know if we get along really
well so I guess I'm tripping I don't
know man
just calling to see what you think about
it I'm not trying to brag I'm just
trying to get a little input on how I
should approach it from here on out gang
bro like your attitude man it doesn't
sound like you're trying to break so I
like that you have that awareness though
to try and think about that that's a
nice gift some people don't have that
you know I think a lot of it some of its
gonna be out of your control you can
only control what you can control
so how she behaves is nothing you could
really do to affect that especially if
you're trying to be on the up-and-up
if you're not trying to trick her
something so a problem I did I mean I
can only relate in the ways I errors
that I made I put a woman on a pedestal
I'll put her way up here on cloud 60 or
whatever and I should have had her on
cloud three or whatever by me so then
that way on cloud three I can
communicate with her like a you know
just like a peer instead of
communicating her with her like this you
know thing or I'd built her up so much
in my head that I was afraid to even
talk to her so I would just put her on a
level where you can communicate with her
keep her there and I would be honest but
I would just kind of just take it easy
you know slow and steady wins the race
always because what if she's not ready
right now today
but then you you're laying the
groundwork for later you just don't want
to burn the bridge you know you don't
want to burn the bridge while there's
you know while there's before somebody
puts bacon on it or whatever you know
I'm saying so so yeah which I would just
take it easy man if you're not sure if
you should do something don't do it talk
with a buddy but take it easy man and
then you know next time you take her out
do something fun do something exciting
do something you know that's kind of
cool and be confident about whatever
you're gonna do and if she brushes you
off or something then that's okay and if
she doesn't then that's okay too
either way you're good we had some calls
that came in and I wanted I wanna I want
to buzz a couple of these you know cuz
this the baby we got cam we got will we
got the you know we had the magical baby
some guy his wife well let's start right
there we had this this fella let's
listen to a little bit of the call that
came in because his wife had a child and
they didn't know about it but I've never
heard a surprise baby story but the day
after the fourth of July we had a baby
boy and we had no idea that was coming
she took some tests back in November all
came back not pregnant she was having
her cycle fourth of July she thought she
was constipated all day long I was
driving around gonna go to a pool party
listening to King in this thing and you
know she says she's got time to play
didn't feel good so we were gonna go to
the ER together and she ended up going
home going to sleep
I was waiting get that cause you want to
go but I never got a call about her
apartment car was gone
called the hot dogs but that were
getting uh she's been transported there
and came by a dad was outside waiting
for me say I was gonna be a daddy I
remember one time I was all [ __ ] up I
ordered a pizza and didn't know right I
forgotten so mean a little bit later
this person shows up and they're pissed
dude because they tried they've been
knocking at the door for like thirty
minutes bro
so this [ __ ] broke a bunch of
plant pots on my porch and and I mean I
got the pizza but you know it was just
it was horrible Brian never I just it
was stupid but on anyway they you know
you got so anyway yeah sometimes you
maybe you'll get an arrant pizza you
know you get that surprise pie but
rarely do you get a human that drops in
your life that you got to care about
forever unexpectedly so let's check in
with Mike right here hello Big Mike hey
what's up man what's up man this is Theo
von dude how are you today hey I'm doing
good would you think it was another baby
Colin that would be crazy man I don't
really know what I would expect that for
that was yeah it was gonna be twins dude
that's so wild man how was uh tell me
about the baby I want to know cuz you
guys had that surprise baby you guys
weren't expecting it right no we weren't
expecting at all not know he was coming
it's about three hours before he was
born
he's about twice the size he was born
now it's too much shots couple days ago
he's almost 12 pounds and he came out
about six pounds he was tiny man like
spitting in my forearm he was probably
like a week premature oh yeah he only
weighed like my wife only weighs was
she's my girl fat at a time but she only
weighs about like 130
25 pounds oh she's not a big girl man so
the only gained about maybe eight nine
pounds of the baby so I just thought man
she was just getting a belly you know
what I mean oh yeah do winners come and
y'all are getting to know each yelling
yeah you know you kind of know each
other by now so my brother and my dad I
was like how I I tell my girlfriend like
you know she's getting she's getting a
bit of a belly our and they were so you
don't say anything
I didn't I'm gonna spend nothing I was
sneaking little hands like hey like I'm
going to the gym a night like you wanna
you wanna come run the elliptical with
me or something like or hey like that's
your child the whole time this is the
the yeah you know it's my child I mean
getting jacked with your son yeah I mean
a week before he was born we were in
Asheville and we were well on a
three-mile hike in the mountains and
yeah dang this almost sounds biblical
now baby you're getting out there into
the hill I was I was just glad he wasn't
born at that time you didn't know he
didn't know we had no idea man I mean
her stomach was hard you know the like I
just we be cuddling a night and stuff
and I'd had my hand around I mean
nothing ever kicked I mean she was
getting her period every month still
like she cooked a couple tests back in
November and they all came back like not
pregnant she would get sick every now
and then man we'd go to like I mean we
go out you know like I'm 24 she's 20s
you guys went out to the bars and
everything huh yeah we could go out like
the bar hey man did I want to meet this
baby brothers baby likes to [ __ ] go
ham son I like it she's only a hundred
and thirty pounds because I honestly
brought everybody thought she was fat no
man kids like even though I didn't get a
sneaky baby you know what I'm saying
look we've all we all got fat man I got
a huge my ass has too big you know I
have huge ass but but yeah I can't below
and everybody's mind you think of a
larger lady not knowing that they got
that baby in all no exactly she's not
she's not a big girl she's a tiny she's
a tiny woman how do you hide a baby in a
tiny woman dude this is almost like a
you know Siegfried and Roy or some nice
yes she has she has something called
endometriosis mmm-hmm and what the
doctors think is she would believe
sometimes when they think that he was
hiding in the fallopian tube
yeah yeah he was like in some like
hiding under a cyst or something in her
stomach so that's why I like her so many
things work out really though he's a
real sneak this little mf4 huh
now he is man he is and they had about
they had about 12 15 nurses in the way
in like the birthing room with us
because they didn't know what was gonna
happen man nobody knew what was gonna
happen I mean all they could tell us is
that he has a heart like he has a
heartbeat I need to know he was a boy
and so he came out Wow
I was just that whole two hours man I'll
be honest with you I was just freaking
out on how he would come out like
healthy wise yeah I bet oh I can only
imagine at that point you're like Jesus
so you went from not even knowing you
were having a baby
to Ecklie took my that night you were a
father yes sir I use more than one the
morning on July 5th so here it was
almost a fourth of July baby but yeah he
weighed about an hour
damn man jeepers dude yeah it sounds
like he was getting caught up into
something he's hiding out on his mom
he's showing up right at you know after
midnight on the fourth of July it sounds
like he's really looking for trouble
no exactly and what does now did you
guys give him a name or what is it yeah
his name is uh Munro Emerson Baker he's
named after actually not really named
that for anybody man we have a little
tradition in my family with guys we do
em the first name for the middle name
and like an hour before he was born we
were just writing down ideas all
whiteboards and some of the nurses were
helping us out we just cross off the
ones that she liked and the next day
when the whole pregnancy brain was gone
we just kind of picked her when she
liked and that's when she like will move
Monro see so y'all didn't have a um
y'all didn't have a like a crib or
anything at home for him bro we had we
had Jesus Christ we didn't even have a
car seat to leave with man they had they
go we had to get a car see Cathy was a
premature baby yeah we got your nation
but shoutouts all the prematures to do
that if you don't get any respect man
dang yeah glad you a car seat test they
had taken for a couple hours ride around
a car with and make sure his heart rate
wouldn't go up or anything that's like
when the police when you go ride with
the police or whatever and see him get
up digital so he's just waiting into the
world and how's he doing now he's doing
good man he's completely healthy you got
a big-ass head home he's gotten that
high percentile head got a little little
chubby but I mean he was small man but
like they say he's perfectly healthy now
he meant he got all his shots a couple
of days ago he's up to up the speed he's
and all that no he's just we're just
kind of hanging out right now until I'm
trying to I'm in construction it's like
I'm trying to build a little starter
home right now so I'm trying to do
something like that and we're just kind
of living in between places but yeah
very good
well I see what you're why I mean I just
wonder if you what else you what your
wife's next big reveal you know it's
open nothing wild man I don't know I
need to calm down a little while do you
might want to get her a um a
breathalyzer or something you know see
if she's spent you know if she's gonna
have another one or not breathalyzer but
uh what's that thing where they hook you
up and see if you're telling the truth a
polygraph yeah get her that Polygram
dude you know what I'm saying no you
didn't you weren't like laying there
you weren't lever laying there it's felt
the baby kick or anything they never
could kick it aw man we hang we hang out
every single day man they have a Zia
Maya this just sounds so wild and then I
have pictures that we went to this gala
in Wilmington for this big festival
thing back the beginning of May when she
was probably like seven months and we
have pictures like of her and me and I
mean you just can't even tell man I have
a lot of pictures I mean I
the picture the night before we went
hiking we were out in Asheville and she
had this tight little dress on real real
big but I mean I just thought that I was
you know you know I was going to have a
good night yeah I think that I didn't
think that they were just bigger than
usual em tits yeah and what about were
y'all doing drugs or anything like that
because that seems like it'd be wild I
mean I guess I can I can't I I can kind
of talk about this now I guess there's
like we were truthful to the social
workers and the right way of what we
were doing during the pregnancy because
we had no idea but I mean yeah we did I
mean through the week before in the
mountain we did a little hell yeah boy
I'll [ __ ] do something if I had it
bro but I can't do it but I want some I
want to [ __ ] get some bro but I can't
but whatever dog we thinking about that
dog but damn brother I'm saying you guys
might have that new way to do birthing
that you know just kind of let it do its
thing you do your thing and then y'all
meet up when it's time you know for the
baby to show out in the world
exactly I think it all worked out in its
own because we wouldn't be together when
we conceived him and we were talking
stuff like that and I think we knew that
she was pregnant we probably would have
had to force ourselves to be together
and everything Wow it all just kind of
worked itself out in a way and then I
mean a couple weeks after he was
conceived I was in a pretty pretty bad
car accident
hmm crushed up truck and then I mean I
didn't know why I was still walking
around I guess that I mean he you know
eight months later I kind of figured out
why hey man bruh yeah that's cool dude
damn and so it sounds like yeah you
sound like you're in good spirits now so
things are kind of cruising along pretty
good yeah I'm pretty good can't use me
like a yourself urgency kind of thing
makes it a little bit get going a little
more at work trying to get stuff done
yeah I like then if even if I'm having a
bad day I know I'm gonna come home to
him and I get some going get it that's
exciting huh
it is exciting man it's just like a
family that I didn't expect to get so
soon but I got it and I'm happy man wow
that's crazy man Wow bro what a crazy
story man I know it's pretty wild me her
uncle he's in filming and stuff and
doing up so high oh the other weekend he
did this little production video stuff
with us and he's trying to send it into
the PLC right now and he gets it all
edited out for that TV show Oh
interesting yeah I mean yeah I guess I
guess there's people having surprise
children out there yeah and that's what
Thank You Man like if I was watching
that show before our figures before Ally
I do not know I do not know that your
wife or whatever is pregnant but managed
you put on [ __ ] man yes it's the
real stuff I guess and [ __ ] behind
and [ __ ] man let's be honest dude I'm
saying brah so a chart the other day it
says six out of 11 [ __ ] be keeping
secrets so I mean you know it could
happen
it'll in hindsight if would you is there
any warning signs you would give to
fathers who who who may not realize
they're about to be a father something
that they can look like looking back is
there any way a guy could tell maybe
that his wife is pregnant maybe anything
you should look out for like she would
get sick sometimes if you see your
girlfriend or your wife sporadically
throwing up randomly think to have it in
the back of your mind cuz I mean she
would never even have food urges man
like I think that think that whole thing
is a myth too like if someone thinks
that they're pregnant they feel like
they just whatever they want because
they ever be a time there was never a
time where she would be like Kayla still
give this to eat your hailer still get
to see it was just a regular eating
schedule mean she was even on a keto
diet like nowadays where she wouldn't
eat so three or four in the [ __ ]
afternoon dude these films of amazing
broke drugs keto this baby could
probably pledge a frat bro hey
[Music]
dude that's amazing man Monroe brother
yeah was wild man
that's why story well uh well dude is it
cool if we check in every now and then
on this baby do because this thing I I
can't I don't know what he might do next
you know no he would probably be just
not even making noise come on behind
somebody track yeah I'm like is he a
mime how do you stay still for nine
months
yeah Wow man well look this is an
exciting story because for me it just
made it reminds me that there's
possibility in the world and that
anything can kind of happen in that you
know that uh just that thing you know
just that the that things can occur
sometimes we get so stagnant thinking
that nothing you know there might not be
any magic left in the world but as
definitely the sounds about is almost
mystical as you could get
it is van keulen with her light in
Demetrio systems and stuff and her
family jeans I mean she didn't think
that she'd be having really any kids
anytime soon and in my history I mean I
got a bad history with like drugs and
[ __ ] like that so I mean I didn't really
think I could produce like that you know
what I mean and I guess we should I mean
she was on that strong ass birth control
man they shoot in your arm and Jesus bro
that's like [ __ ] they got at the zoo
brought us that strong strand man
exactly damn boy
well Dean do you guys are really I can't
wait to see what y'all do next man hey
man y'all can call whenever you want
okay we will man will check in with the
maybe we send Nick a picture so we have
a just a image we can put up of Monroe
yeah Mac you know we actually do like
the little family portrait things that
my mom's last year Maggie
the picture of him or like all of us
yeah that'd be cool man is your mother
excited about having a grandchild oh
yeah miss all over the place cool man
well it sounds like you guys almost got
force-fed kind of like a new beginning
in a weird way exactly yeah well I hope
you make the most of a man again
congratulations on your son I appreciate
it man thanks for calling yeah you bet
bro we'll talk to you soon man and tell
that secret agent I said to keep it
low-key you know all right take care
brother
I mean yes to talk about peace Wow
I can't I mean I've waited for it you
know I've had things show up I didn't
expect you know we got that all that
plastic wrap come at one time but man
imagine you tickling your girlfriend and
then you got a child that's what I mean
you know imagine just anything y'all go
you know you have a couple of hands you
know a couple ham steaks or whatever and
then BAM you know you got a child or
anything you watching a movie an hour
later you got a [ __ ] child by me it
never stops they got that magic baby out
there so possibility possibility you
know there is a result there's always
this something around the corner
something you just got to hold the line
and get there mmm and to the gentleman
that called before him the you know
there's the this could be something
great that's right around the corner but
even if whatever is right around the
corner isn't if even though even if it's
not perfect or it's not the best or what
you've been wishing for praying for it's
gonna be there's gonna be something else
there's gonna be someone else there's
gonna be another
opportunity I think it's only
opportunity that's right around the bend
usually you know if you're if you're
keeping your head up in your eyes
forward and your heart open I think it's
only opportunity that's around the
corner for you so I think that uh you
know we got somebody's funny you know
right there a guy you know a woman he
thought it's out of his League and
suddenly they're playing you know they
playing t-ball together there you go all
right I want to make a call right now to
cam and he you guys remember his call
was this I got prom with these sweaty
hands my dad I problems it it doesn't
not too worried about it but comes a
problem date oh you got them sweaty
hands huh you got them leaky mitts baby
tell me more just wondering some advice
that maybe you give a young guy sweaty
hands I forgot this one answer oh you
got that drip shake huh
hmm I can only imagine me you try to
shake somebody's hand and you and your
daddy probably can't even handshake
because it's just like uh just like two
like two fists trying to uh just like
two fists trying to hug and they can't
and it's like hmm all right I want to
make a call to my boy cam now you know
your boy had that drool Hand Luke really
and I wanted to uh to check in with him
because a lot of great suggestions came
in for him from different listeners yeah
you guys remember cam he and his father
both had the same situation where they
get extra water on their hands so they
could you know definitely a liability
probably if you you know maybe playing
certain board games or things like that
but also a uniqua tee you know that's a
uniqua tee when you have a special I
mean [ __ ] if God comes looking for an
actual Aquaman then you know they're
gonna have they're gonna be right there
at the front of the line where my dry
ass is gonna be back there at the back
but let's uh let's put a buzz into him
right now
hello big cam what's up what's up
Playboy Co I'm doing okay man you know
I'm getting through
you know me dude I've always got
something wrong with me Thank You Brad I
think I needed to hear that today man
and I appreciate you calling in to about
uh about the hyperhidrosis man you got
those drippy mitts David I want to know
more about it tell me to get like a
shirt drippy mitts on it that I don't
even know if that was the best nickname
either man so I really
yeah well it's interesting dude cuz I
was thinking whenever you were talking
about that I was thinking about it a
couple of days after and I was like cuz
I've always thought you know my hands
look uh look like my mother's hands so I
always thought I had woman's hands so I
remember some intense yeah so when I was
young I would tell if I held a girl's
hand I would always remember I've
forgotten about this I would say you
know I would say I'm not a woman I would
always tell a girl that if I held her
hand or something for some and I'm sure
they were thinking like what in the hell
is this guy talking about but yeah
definitely was anything but it
unfortunately I said some stuff but uh
but yeah I think everybody has just like
something that they feels like
uncomfortable about but I guess with
your hands it would be because that's
like the first thing you reach out to
somebody with sometimes well yeah man I
was talking to a dude today got a good
first impression you know we were
talking about some [ __ ] and then he goes
to shake my hand out me up or whatever
and
to wipe my hand off real quick he didn't
[ __ ] care man like a fox I mean some
people care about it and like when they
do care it's like whatever well it's
funny cuz it makes me think cause
sometimes somebody will shake my hand
and their hand will be if it's cold and
wet then that's when I guess I could get
a little bit alarmed maybe because I'm
like this person like a living are they
gonna live long or what's gonna happen
but if it's just kind of damp usually I
think oh maybe they're just kind of
nerves you know nervous is it is it
nerves that kick-started or what do you
notice yeah I have pretty bad anxiety
problems I think I do everybody else
says they don't notice it I'm fine but
like [ __ ] I guess it's all in my head
like you were talking about like getting
out of your head just the other day and
like I mean it's just all my [ __ ]
head man so like the more I think about
it the worse it gets so like like if I'm
thinking about oh man like gotta get my
hands dry on this go shoulder or
whatever it's like just like going and
then once I get working out man it's
like [ __ ] it's gone cuz I'm working out
and like I'm thinking about like the
other task ahead instead of my [ __ ]
hand sweating yeah yeah man I figure
with my house start to think my hair is
losing out and then I start looking at
it all the time then I started losing
you got [ __ ] killer okay so you just
appreciate it man I thanks dude yeah I
just [ __ ] but yeah it's crazy I we just
get so stuck in our heads man what is
what were some of the things I know some
people suggested Botox and people
suggested that ion ion ion to derma okay
so actually looked into the ion to derma
and I'm actually probably hmm
but I went to the doctor and he gave me
like two solutions he gave me like he
said I could put like this little rub on
my hands I like make some steak hmm or I
could take this a little cab or this
little pill like that were to go out
it's just like
drive me out a little bit you know like
date and then like I could take that
before I've tried it like it works
pretty well like it's trying like I can
feel it literally like sucking the damn
like moisture Adam yeah it works dude
that could be more of a problem do you
might be that dry daddy you know I know
so true bruh so what did the I answered
Irma what is it like I looked into it I
think it's like some sort of like
electrical [ __ ] I don't know how there
can be a like electrical [ __ ] in water I
mean you're just killing like something
inside a man just like makes your hands
it's dark arts whereas sounds like be
like past 10 o'clock seems a little
sketchy man I definitely get no [ __ ]
Botox ya freak man leaking from my face
like you can sweat from other places if
you prevent that like I don't want to
start sweating from some crazy place on
my body that you normally don't some
yeah that's true me you don't yeah
that'd be crazy if you just started kind
of like just dripping off your lobes all
the time or something yeah
cam did I love your attitude man thanks
for the good words and uh and yeah man I
just appreciate you like just kind of
even just like me making me think about
what that's like so if I shake
somebody's hand and their hand is a
little damp like in the future at least
I know hey man maybe this maybe they
have this and then I can discuss it with
them you know him and
like you say you don't like your nose
man will like what if you had that
[ __ ] note on your hand like I mean
yeah what if every time I just yeah yeah
everybody's got that thing man it's true
bro and it's funny because the thing is
I bet if we traded and had somebody
else's I wonder if we would be like
relieved or if we would be like [ __ ] man
I want my old thing back [ __ ] man I wish
we could man I could get your nose for a
[ __ ] day you take my sweaty oh dude I
would moonwalk on my hands it's the
first thing I would [ __ ] do that well
dude thanks for calling in dude and um
yeah we'll be in touch man we'll reach
out and say hey sometime so yeah maybe
before if you hear that I'm coming man
reach out or something and we'll get you
some tickets oh yeah that would be great
you can shake the trippy Mets [ __ ] yeah
but let's double down dude
let's double down all right bro have a
good day man I'll talk to you soon take
it easy man or you too cam gang bro
peace man you gotta love that you gotta
love his energy right there let's take a
call that came in right here onwards hey
Theo this is Chris from Wisconsin what's
up Chris from WI and Green Bay really
had this showing out they showed out
yesterday homework uh I just wanted to
call and let you know that your your
podcast has really helped out quite a
bit man about two years ago my wife went
through a hemorrhage after we had our
our baby girl and oh man sorry to hear
that brother thanks for uh thanks for
sharing that more it's pretty serious
you could you could pass away after that
so uh anyway oh yeah it's serious man
I mean he'll do two other guys girl with
they're out there doing drugs or
something the babies I mean the baby's
not trying to get out so that's really
you know if you're doing drugs and a
baby is trying to get out of your body
that's almost like a damn episode of CSI
SUV or whatever but um word sent my mind
in a spiral and she had to get taken
away by ambulance and stuff and I uh I
thought that uh man I'm gonna have to
raise these two kids solo and do without
my mom my partner my love everything Wow
yeah sorry to have joked around man
that's a pretty that's a real deal right
there I can't imagine that you know that
you brought your your lady rolling off
there in that little hope wagon that's
all I ambulance is bruh and and that
you're not sure what your future is
gonna look like you know all these
things flash into your head homework
something my mind going man and I went
into a pretty a pretty messed up place
for actually about two years and it was
right around when I started listening to
your podcast man and I just wanted to
let you know this Union you know it
might not be the same thing but you know
other people are going through stuff too
and and yourself and all that and yeah
man it's just uh yeah it's just kind of
listening and it helped and helped a lot
and happy to say like two years after
that my head is great my family is great
my wife is great
you know I hope you're taking care of
yourself man but your podcast has done a
lot to help dude I I appreciate it we
look forward to coming back to Milwaukee
Gang Gang Gang Gang man thanks for that
call yeah I will be I'll be in Milwaukee
soon but yeah man it's just it's so
crazy how it will change it all changes
that's it's going to happen so if
somebody's broken your heart or if
somebody's done this or if somebody's
done that you know or if you fell in
love or you fell out of love or you fell
into a job or you've decided not to take
a job like me
you know if you or don't know if you're
making the right choice are not making
the right choice whatever you're feeling
right now is gonna change if it's bad
it's that it's gonna change and even if
it's good it's gonna change you know I
get sometimes hooked on I think you know
I have such a short-term memory
emotionally so that's why I make a lot
of the same mistakes sometimes because I
my emotions they just don't remember
what what just occurred you know and so
I'll just just I got short-term memory
you know and that's why I'm like oh well
how did I find myself here again it's
because I just I don't know it just you
know it forgets your feelings forget but
then maybe that's one of the beautiful
things about them too man if your
feelings remembered all the hurt all the
time
oh you know I mean sometimes they
remember enough of it if that's all they
remembered that would just be we really
wouldn't be a very unique creature man
we really wouldn't be a special creature
um yeah we relate we relate we relate
and we forget how much we can relate to
one another don't we we forget that yeah
man when I saw just everybody's man
everybody's got something everybody's
going through something and that's the
that's what that's where we're the same
you know that's where we're the same and
and through each other we can find you
know a little bit of opportunity to to
feel better I think a lot of times if
we're not feeling good but we get
through it we keep going onward we keep
going onward that's it you know you get
up and you dust your feet off for your
legs off or something if you if you got
dust on your legs and
or whatever wherever you got dust and
you just we you know we live to fight
another day we live to fight another day
whether we're fighting with our heart or
with our head or with our hands you know
we live to learn another day you know
when we brush ourselves off and we put
ourselves back out there in the store
window because somebody might see us we
might see somebody you know we might be
able to be an inspiration for someone or
somebody might be able to be an
inspiration for us we just we stay in
there we stay in the we stay in the mosh
pit we stay in the mosh pit man and we
keep going on or brother that's what it
is so anyway what else is going on with
me I don't know I just appreciate all
the calls and a lot of really just
people calling them with what's going on
and a lot of people being really real
about what's happening in our lives and
it makes me feel connected to people man
it really does it makes me feel a little
more human than when I when I sat down
in this chair today
I mean it's anything is possible
anything is possible
you could start turning into Aquaman you
could have a kid pop out of a chick you
know and just say it's yours you know
what I'm saying it's great anything is
possible there's a lot of unique things
there's a lot of opportunity you've got
to get up and you got to do it I'm gonna
do it man I'm gonna keep going bro
anyway sorry if this got a little down
in Dow or I you know I don't know but
whatever bro I'm also not sorry dude I
don't even know who I am sometimes but
I'm [ __ ] keep trying to figure it out
boy let's take a song right here man
let's get us out of here
and and we got it we got it
you guys be good to your salesmen you
deserve it brother and sisters gagging
gagging here's bishop gun anything you
want
[Applause]
[Music]
anything you want man
I got to get some more types of music
huh
[Music]
[Applause]
the approach to a reality
[Music]
[Music]
thank you guys for your support man it
means a lot
[Music]
still my best man we're doing our best
you know
[Music]
[Music]
Lester
me don't make the skin
[Music]
me
[Music]
you guys take care of yourselves man
gang